Oh JUnit guys we're officially doing
Road rules man haha great yeah you guys
know what this thing does the panties
stops them then drops yeah chicks love
dudes with RVs my uncle drives one gets
laid all the time yeah he's a coke
dealer also so that might have something
to do that's probably what it did to buy
the RV mmhmm yeah and I want the best
bet cuz I'm probably gonna be doing some
funds and we all know yes yes but
whoever touches the RV first gets it
wait no what no oh you sucker damn it
Adam you have to give us a little bit of
advance notice yeah whoever touches the
other side gets to control the radio
ready set go
look I said ready set go so hahaha yeah
ah hey Montez we're just gonna take a
tour of the RV if that's cool
look we don't take your garbage okay
yeah big bag fold double-ended dildos I
was you'd probably strap on this is this
Evan stone what's he doing that is that
Evan stone he's my favorite man x $1,200
worth of premium sex toys got some for
Colleen for a 10-year anniversary made
her a music video but it's all over me
okay why is that cuz she cheating over
me wait did she did she tell you that uh
but she didn't say anything about like
who it might be you're like what the
person looks like right I heard her on
the phone talking about she worried
about getting the STD like she got some
kinda thing called coochie mold awesome
did I actually just want a foot race so
I'm entitled to the best bed so is that
in the front hey you can't use this
anymore dummy I'm living in there okay
for sure like what happened to my life I
had it all tell you what man if I catch
just do
cut his dick off I was gonna take it in
this Griffin put it in a microwave and
cooking uh oh right yeah cuz like
cheaters we hate them they make me sick
but you know maybe you should treat them
nice I'm gonna go uh throw up cuz I'm so
sick of hearing about your horrible
situation man
you